we are Carly and Aaron I'm Carly
I'm Aaron and we have a YouTube channel
together called Carly and Aaron
we are z-list youtubers yeah we're David
and Jason yep we do out we do comedy
vlogs three times a week so today we're
gonna be picking these dramatic scenes
out of a bowl and creating them
ourselves and it'll probably be really
bad
I don't ask Jace is an actual actor he
had two movies both bombed but he did
afternoon oh that's a shot I like this
one boss lays off employee on Christmas
Eve that's a good one for you and go
Jeremy hi had mr. botanical um I see you
been working at the printer really
nicely today yes I have and can I say
thank you for this job about the job yes
you're fired
no mr. botanical we need to make room no
please I need this job I need you to get
out of my office right now
No get out of my office I can't do that
get out of my office right now
understand I have a baby squirrel at
home you have a what I found it baby
squirrel he had a rare disease he has no
butt hole and so the reason I need this
job is because he is a surgery and you
can let me go but I just want you to
think about that little squirrel how
much do you need I need seven thousand
and one dollar
that's the one I'd like to look you can
let me go I can I can walk out that door
right now I can't anymore
I can't so I can stay no you can't you
gotta [ __ ] go oh yeah I was just
trying to entertain you I have an acting
class I met there improv over there on
UCB oh you're done at UCB you gotta get
out of my office I don't know what's
happening yeah sure
dentists telling patient he/she will
need all their teeth removed um I'll be
the dentist
thank you for coming in today
yeah no problem is everything okay with
my teeth we are going to need to extract
all of your teeth all all of every last
one why do you need to take out all of
my all of my teeth the top and bottom
like every yes why sometimes it just
happens this way we need to take your
teeth and give them to someone in need I
don't think you need to take out all of
my teeth what am I gonna tell I'm 22
years old I only will have gum wait
you're not explaining anything to me
you're taking out literally all of my
ideas so you want me to look like a
crazy person are you gonna like give me
fake teeth are you gonna like replace it
with anything what's gonna happen if you
want we can definitely offer that option
for you of dentures it'll be around 20
to 40 thousand what if I can't afford
this well there is actually one thing we
can do there is one tooth inside of your
mouth that we won't need to donate we
can put it in a little locket for you
you know locket to just remind me that I
have a mouthful of gum yeah I don't know
I don't know I don't even want it I'm
gonna dump it I'll take it I'll just
frame it so whenever my people I meet
come over but yeah this is what my dog
paint but here's my booth on the wall
like I'm really upset about the fact
that you're telling me I need all of my
teeth taken out I could just leave and
not get this done and I would oh no no
you have to you will die this is like
the weirdest day of my life I mean if
I'm gonna die then I guess I'm sorry
[Music]
son caught my father smoking weed
Julius can I speak with you for a second
Romeo get out of here and talk to my dad
yes Romeo the cat get out of here
I found weed in my Mini Cooper last
night would you know anything about that
no no no okay so that's not your weed
let me tell you something brother you
think that you can come in this house
and bring your weed I hate when you go
all Hulk Hogan on me well let me tell
you something brother
I am Hulk Hogan okay serious dad no but
I'm his biggest super fan oh when I get
mad brother I turn into Hulk Hogan and
soon I think we did pretty pretty weird
it awful I think we did really well
phenomenal yeah we're gonna be able to
quit YouTube now I'd like another shot
at it
no let's just take it as a loss and okay
like literally what can't we do um
dishes okay yeah
oh no basketball the prawn tape screw
LeBron James squirrel gave you Channing
Tatum squirrel yeah guys this is a great
squirrel I liked it like the way you to
a squirrel
you